traditionally we think of legacy as  um you know what are they gonna say  about me when i die and how much money  did i have and what are the  accomplishments that are gonna show up  in my o bit or what you know is my name  gonna be on a building for the you know  very few people but  really we all have a legacy and that is  completely detached from accomplishments  or or your bank account or social  approval because in every interaction  that we have throughout the day  has an impact and there are ripple  effects that go from that so to think  about legacy not as we're nearing the  end of our professional lives but to  really embody or to be contemplating  legacy even as a young person i think is  a really powerful lever for how you  think about constructing your life and  the you know avenues for your energy and  attention